and as predicted Gail the Bellas are in
over their heads lost in a sea of semen
[Music]
[Music]
you guys just sing other people's songs
right oh my god
guys stop they just don't like sharing
the spotlight so they're trying to
intimidate us let's just take the high
road and do what I do I think what I'll
bacon my knees like a riff-off
[Music]
coming up so you go
[Music]
[Music]
with all my Bella say what about our
destiny were Jewish
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what do you sing tonight a little who
run the world some bulletproof you
didn't tell us what the crowd was but
sheet I um I brought up this just make
Oh God
our voices are warm we didn't invite you
guys to sing we invited you to watch us
sing Alka scuse me I just thought you
guys were so busy with your your awesome
jobs and amazing lives I have one of
those yeah all right ladies pick up your
tips we're going out what do you mean
going out what do you mean what do I
mean we just sucked balls in front of DJ
Khaled hmm listening he's staying at
that fancy casino hotel across the
street okay I say we all get up we get
dressed we go over there and we show him
that we are not a joke
Emily I can't believe that a half-decent
ID came out of your dumb mouth thank you
okay so let's get tot it up it's had it
and toss it gently Santosh it up she
means to she's the caramel tart
she's a chocolate tart you're the
vanilla tart
thanks babe mmm Oh tarted targets easy I
will just say [ __ ]
that's the ladder that will take you up
to the main deck where the Bellas are do
not live tickets here what I'm doing
below okay giant distraction coming up
you sure about this I let you down
dozens of examples spring to mind if I'm
honest yeah you're very unreliable it's
like one of the hallmarks of your
personality I don't think we have time
to unpack that right now Shh
I'll just say up top nobody's gonna die
tonight right
Yeah right yeah well that doesn't help
okay okay ready I've got my serious face
on now okay it's time let's do it
we're always gonna be there for each
other it's for family Becca don't I
swear to God don't make that face if you
cry I'm gonna cry I'm not gonna do this
with you today so I hate that face you
know how much I love you you just get
out there and you crush it okay you
crush it so hard that your lips tingle a
bit she loves to be most amazing group
of women I have ever known
hey I'm gonna do anything to sing with
you guys again
wait wait wait wait wait I'm having a
crazy idea
okay I've mentioned that my dad is in
the army and like basically killed Osama
bin Laden right so no information in
that sentence but okay well what I mean
is he's kind of a big deal in the army
and every year the USO puts on this
performance to entertain and support the
troops and this year dj khaled is
hosting he's got like that gazillion hit
songs and you super famous I saw him on
a tax commercial what if I could get us
an invite just say no to run military
dark ops yes of course to sing
you